all right what a misfire corner how does
it feel to be the shorter one now I got
I was gonna bring in our chair but okay
I could be sitting like this that would
look really silly awesome I'm just like
trying to go like this little 10 but
okay um so okay so there's there's two
twists in this ending what I like what
I'm kind of uh the one I think is is
that the person she falls in love with
and is the prince looking after the
place turns out it's all a diabolical
scheme he's really a jerk he just wants
the kingdom because he's not gonna get
his own Kingdom um and he betrays her
and it leads to kind of the
misunderstanding and the bit worth uh
the guy has yeah whatever the love
interest really the misunderstanding no
not really okay okay the love interest
doesn't go into the place when he drops
her off which is strange it's only so he
can have a conversation with himself to
head back which those bore the hell out
of me but it's short um so he walks away
you know it's like Oh she'll just have
to do without me and this or has a fake
conversation with the Moose and comes
running back reindeer a traitor excuse
me uh that is true bones would be a
zoologist fashion I was offended I was
so honest people are offended by
anything they really are um so okay so
uh and it leads to this climax the
climax for the most part I felt was not
that interesting that's where I'm sort
of like a like cuz we had the cool thing
with the snow monster earlier and in the
snow cast so I'm like could we do
something like that again could the
monster come back I mean it's kind of
unfair that he dies there was a lot of
flimsy pretext to get everybody in the
right position to make that work out
just right and it really wasn't cleverly
written yeah everything else feel hammy
see they need and I didn't know exactly
where was going I've not read the
original fairy tale it's supposedly
based on and from what I've been told by
every review and everybody on the planet
apparently needed to Disney because they
changed a thousand things
yeah I made it it doesn't matter to me
that's classic Disney um but watching it
I was just like I don't know where
exactly this story's going but I know
it's very obvious they want all of these
characters on this frozen lake
yeah and it's painful the way they were
just getting them there for reasons yeah
and the way it's so everything else is
so visually interesting in this climate
you're just looking at white snow go by
and fog and it's just not that
interesting um but the other twist that
I thought it's so friggin ingenious is
that uh Anna is dying
the sister accidentally sends the cold
thing again into her heart again that's
the part that comes back why they had to
be separated which is clever again they
really show it there and uh the act of
true love is going to warm the heart of
it it's the only way to save it so make
it know they even keep saying well we
have to give it to the Prince so that
they can kiss you know like loves true
love's true kiss uh well then rinse is a
DJ yeah he's a teenager
so that wha BC it's got to be the blonde
guy you know yeah we've been with but
and then they got me there I am we got
that year ago and I was a myself but
wouldn't that go against what they're
saying with knowing each other for only
a few days and stuff like that I after
one day like one does not work and sure
enough they have it where the sister
sees uh the Queen she's about to get
killed by the bad guy she goes in there
and stops the sword from coming down
that freezes her that quote-unquote
kills her great image and it is like
okay that was really solid everything
you needed to get to that point was yeah
but and and and that is the act of love
because she loves her sister and then
she melts and lives happily ever and
gets all sappy but you know that's
Disney that's mine but it was so it
really made you think I was gonna go in
this one direction that would have
really gone against pretty much
everything they were building up and
instead goes this other one and again it
shows the connection between the sisters
and and the love they have for each
other and it's just so well done and
what happens with uh with the princess
character and the blonde
if they they're a couple but getting
their even up there they don't have that
first kiss till the very end yeah I mean
so it is also us in a white but uh yeah
but that was creepy yes so so you got
this thing going on where they're just
gonna start their own relationship we go
see where goes and it's just man is that
hard to balance out while still being a
Disney product and still being
entertaining and just so well done and
I'm really up in the air because on the
one hand I actually didn't like making
the other prints a complete douchebag
like it just flips on a dime and like I
thought actually if they were if they
were gonna be mature about it I thought
maybe he would end up maybe going with
the the ice queen or yeah they're just
you have to Kate power and be like I've
done by but of course like no we need to
make him a douche bag so I don't really
liked it but at the same time I'm just
like then how would you have gotten to
the point that we did like with you know
him trying to take her out and yeah it's
I'm not saying it's an easy fix because
like I said by God I'm impressed that
got as much as they do and it's the same
issue I have with a lot of Disney films
where it's we're gonna be like all
feminist about this and though these
girls will be real characters and
they'll kick ass and yet she's still
like completely I mean he's like oh well
your sisters dead and she's like no and
since they're just waits to get stabbed
and I'm like well what happened to the
ass-kicking characters then again I was
like then you still couldn't have gotten
to that scene so I'm like mmm unwinnable
survive okay okay if her sisters dead
though I mean that would still like you
don't really take a lot out of Kato
again it just always amuses me how this
is like we've got these two ass-kicking
female characters and then the end it
gets down to well we've got to have a
couple dudes come in to move the plot
along
no no but okay but they are not saving
the day in fact honestly I love it when
odd and somebody just exploded sorry oh
we're at a dangerous neighborhood ah
okay but uh my realtor lied today okay
so okay whatever point well the only I
was gonna say is yeah is that you know
the the Queen goes you know goes off in
a band everybody leaves winter and the
princess says no this is my problem I'll
go and get her
you Prince you stay behind looking after
the place I got my horse I'm gonna
bridle she's fixing all the problems
like she was fighting okay okay it's
funny you bring that up because I was
the one thing that i sat there and i
laughed and i even though he was gonna
be a villain let yet but I'm just like
did I not turn to that I'm just like
when she takes off I'm like yes great
plan let's have this random foreigner no
no but that makes sense because of how I
get and okay and they set up why she
would randomly fall in love with this
person - because she's isolated from
people's obviously the feeling she's
having is no ed but that's the reason
she left him behind as well it's not a
smart choice but it makes sense cuz we
remove of course you the only one I
trust you make something a character
perspective but it's incredibly stupid
I'll just show you sense like only know
but of course but that's part of the fun
is mapping I was like how I was like is
there no thing is this not a
constitutional monarchy is there no
third person in charge because I'm like
oh crap
okay well my Queens an eyesore the
Queens and I sorceress okay well I is
the last the next in line
acting future monarch and now abdicate
the throne to go out unguarded by the
way to find her in the middle of this
blizzard um you random foreigner I just
fell in love with yesterday but that you
now are running the show but I think
that's the character though is that she
wouldn't do that
and nobody around her is like um Your
Majesty you can't just abdicate to
random Prince's from foreign X but
that's Disney how come he doesn't freeze
to death when all the snow falls aren't
you pulling a water
my only point is my suspension of
disbelief goes pretty far but at one
point like I seriously was like hey wait
a second by I need that seat to me
that's the Disney stuff um you know
that's just a little things like just
kingdom I know if you're in charge or
enjoy I know it's nitpicky I guess my my
only point is like I don't let Nick
picky things bother me unless I have a
flash in the middle of the movie like
wait because if that happens it does
take me out of it for a second like who
the fuck is this guy I hope I find cuz I
feel it through the character in the
care what they know and the motivation
stuff it it made sense mom ain't him to
be the villain to do this to that I
would have thought it much more music if
he just instigated a coup so um yeah and
like I said with the climax it's not
it's not all that it's bad or that the
twists and turns are bad it's just not
as great as the other stuff like I said
the third act is good where everything
else I feels great um so the high point
is really that song in the middle where
is she no good deed goes a pyre song out
of a song from wicked baby yeah and it's
just that I can only describe it it's
like and I love saying this about a
family film
it's the fuck this shit so yeah no she
literally just is wandering around using
her snow powers and it's just one grand
song version of fuck fish I'm gonna do
what I want like that was the highlight
of the movie and it's not that the rest
isn't good but it's like that was like
the top point and the rest it kind of
just like plateaus or dips and goes back
up and down but it yeah that moment was
so strong and I honestly think the
moment where the sister comes in to try
to talk her out of it that was really
strong too uh but yeah that that third
act it's like it leads to such a great
moment but yeah yeah there is so flimsy
it is one of those where it's like when
that the whole movie I was just engulfed
enjoying all of it and went that point
have you know when they hit the point
where he's the bad guy and there's a
coup and the guy as the ER guys be
convinced to go back I'm that's what I'm
saying yeah how long is this movies turn
to but like I said when when the sister
saves the other sister um that's where
really felt okay this like you said it's
like okay we need to do this to get
here got it I we should go feel better
but I don't know sagen yeah I'm just I
am torn because on the one hand both
sisters end up in an incredible position
of weakness for something where they
were really setting that any character
any character has to go through a
weakness I mean I don't think it's
because well because they're women it's
like Oh what we had especially cuz the
guys do not save I wasn't finished and
she has the choice between which website
I wasn't finished sorry sir but it leads
to the point where both sisters end up
making basically end up becoming the
central focus I mean the prince himself
he just ends up being some dude with a
sword I mean it really ceases to be
about the two guys there and about the
two sisters again so yeah I'm kind of
torn like I'm like okay we dealt back
into a lot of cliche but it ended up to
a really good point it's actually kind
of like Korra
man think about how yeah I don't in
circles to get to a point we really like
um so yeah I'm really torn what what
drives me nuts is you didn't have to be
so cliche about it getting there cuz
that scene where he pretty much is like
odd he snuffs out the find he's like and
now I'm going to take over the kingdom
she's like you'll never get away with
this oh yeah
I'm like really that full you had so
many good lines in this there's a lot of
you through a second she said you're
never gonna get away with this I did
like a head sack and then when he smiled
yeah I was just like listen this like
seriously yeah so I'm like rule of thumb
by the way movie villains don't say
you've already gotten away with
something until the person you're trying
to screw is already dead
they're still alive you haven't gotten
away well let's be honest this guy's
plan doesn't make a whole lot of sense
either why the hell would he keep the
Ice Queen a liar that yeah why the hell
they keep her alive you know he could
just get one right there it's like why
do you bring her back right but that's
what bothers me with so cliched is I
believe you which is slowly freeze to
death muha it was going so well juggling
the other cliche or keeping those
cliches away instead of creating
something that is so old-school like guy
with the twirling his mustache tie the
girl to the railroad tracks sort of just
me yeah that that's what spot and that's
what I'm saying it's like it really went
into that old damsel in distress cliche
now it dug itself out of it so I'm torn
because I was like this is really
obnoxiously bad sitting through this but
it dug itself out of it
yeah a very good way that I'm like it
I'm like I feel there's a stronger way
to get where they were yeah but there
must have been but again we're writers
we know about deadlines we know the
stuff that happens and everything and
when it wasn't a one-person screenplay
I know I thought was I thought I thought
it's like three honestly yeah I got you
some old directors and one other writer
I thought we'd have to check the credits
again I thought it said screenplay by
and I like because we were blanket
brushed by really quickly I thought it
was one person oh good made the story
goes by three people I I don't know I
know the two directors and one other
person that worked on the story or this
and overall it's actually a pretty
strong screenplay but yeah I feel like
easier that's the ending really kind of
like but yeah I mean it's it's a
momentary sort of and I wish I could
have been better to get to a really good
strong point and the first two-thirds I
think are still really good and really
strong so one the dynamic between the
characters is really strong and the one
thing I forgot to mention about the snow
and earlier they also dodged a bullet by
making him a childhood creation
yeah that's true is I don't every
something because it was something that
went back to their childhood in that
memory I actually was giving it a pass
as oh it's like a childhood memory I'll
give him a pass because he's kind of
goofy and well played Disney is the same
thing with the reindeer it's like why
couldn't the gargoyles being Quasimodo
Moto's imagination here the the reindeer
the talky is in his imagination you know
so in the way he's really the way he
talks to that reindeer was it brilliant
I wanted more honestly well yeah
actually annoying to go back I wish he
was doing the voice as well so you can
make that funnier yeah I make that the
argument that he convinced himself
instead of just the radio every day to
push like that could have been stronger
but and you know it's yeah even then I'd
say that's more typical movie cliche
than like Disney cliche like I said just
the bad guy dough which Disney cliche
and that that really took me out of you
seen any visible in movies and oh well
said movies you seen that back I could
okay yeah but doesn't he disney milks
that and he I was let me this week for
something that is trying to capture the
spirit of Disney and trying not to just
be the same old Disney film that was a
major misstep yeah
but the rest of it is really good don't
get me wrong I'm not saying it's a bad
movie that was the one thing that stuck
out to me cuz like that is old-school
Disney in a bad way like you were
getting so much old-school Disney the
good way that to bring that sort of
character back and and particularly
flipping the flipping on a dime didn't
bother me as much it's just like really
you're gonna flip on a dime and become
this squish aid of a care yeah um I mean
cuz because there's kind of a decent
twist honestly you know when he said you
know he does though Oh somebody's in
love you it's are like Oh like you know
what about a coming actually it actually
caught me by surprise just because I
thought where they were going was they
were going to give him to the older
squid yeah and they were gonna be a it
is that nice - they don't on agenda
which is for that so it's just the way
they got there yeah and that last third
yeah and the Raven that the focus is not
as much you know potato with The Snow
Queen I mean there's never an emphasis
to her you need to marry someone which
okay not just being you know a pretty
time period sorry going into a queen
hood but yeah being a political figure
you think there'd be like you know don't
we need to marry need to marry and it's
just not there and it's just nice and
refreshing and it makes sense cuz she's
had no human contact I would yeah no
like that that's why I makes its whities
even yeah and that's why it makes sense
for the other one to to go and you know
just be in love with whoever she sees
for the first time but the other one at
least has been in the palace I really
get the impression the older sister was
completely sequestered whereas the other
one got to play and run around the past
in his hand much more human contact you
know at least that's the way they were
setting up the personality so they did
the same thing in wreck-it Ralph which I
like when they you find out you know
spoilers right Ralph the glitches like a
princess he character and she's like you
have a fence about me we're not going
there and I was like thank you like you
know it's the opposite of what Disney
does where you know a lot of times it's
like let's create an interesting area at
the end I gotta get married that's what
bothered me about Princess and the Frog
I'm like yours a great character at the
end it's like oh you just did the same
damn thing again but she didn't get
married though we should going to come
on there and thank them writing out of
the well come on like the other two in
this aren't gonna get married though
I want the younger sister and yeah yeah
but she was an idiot there was a head up
from the beginning she's the debts of
the groom I'm talking about the older
smarter one okay you should know yeah
but nice dog at least I'm the humble one
oh but but they're still you got a
couple there it's gonna get married
though I need still fine but at least
we've got two couples and oh my god and
what is that evil or bad for like not
why you may or not get a man say it's
like just not even it's just not even a
thing I just like it's like whatever
yeah no no it got thank God yeah so it's
just some real real nice stepping stones
in a good entertaining movie you're good
songs good animation just just good go
see it okay I just want to bring one
thing up you're talking me about being
humble whose face is plastered all over
the website a little loony toons logo
yeah that's what I thought
I should you hold